stockholmers are on their way home for
the weekend when the latest blow to
their country's hopes of joining NATO
was announced turkey would let Finland
in but not yet Sweden the main reason
turkey has claimed that the government
in Stockholm is harboring what Ankara
calls terrorist groups particularly the
Kurdistan Workers Party the pkk
nowadays
has a black market here Sweden NoDa and
talking on Earth and turkey will Sweden
take it seriously is a Kurdish
journalist who came to Sweden in 2005.
he watched in January's tensions between
turkey and Sweden reached their height
when Curtis protesters in Stockholm hung
an effigy of Turkish president Russia
type erdogan in response days demand
that Sweden extradite a list of people
he said will link to the pkk some Kurds
feared that having been given Refuge
they could now be sent back those
protests about NATO and Sweden and
turkey was planned by pkk supporters we
are two different group of course here
in Sweden as I could I have a good life
here Sweden respecting me my language we
will see what will Sweden do as a court
as a Observer I want to see the Swedish
government to take some serious actions
the situation wasn't helped when Danish
right-wing politician Rasmus paladan was
allowed to burn a Quran outside the
Turkish Embassy but whatever happens now
it wasn't meant to be like this for
Sweden who've been stepping up their
military in preparation for joining NATO
it followed Decades of neutrality which
had become part of their identity the
common defense planning that we've been
doing with Finland since 2014 will
become much more difficult it is right
now that the ideas of NATO's new forward
defense is going to be figured out and
in that work it would be a very big
benefit for NATO if they knew if they
could include both Swedish territory but
also Swedish military capabilities
particularly precious to Nato would have
been Swedish technology with its grief
and jets bolstering the alliance's
Airborne capabilities over the Baltic
such an addition to their Armory in
opposition to Russia is now up in the
air
last year Sweden's entry into the
alliance alongside Finland seemed orbit
assured as NATO countries rushed to
welcome them in but with turkia and also
Hungary still having doubts Sweden may
have to wait until the upcoming Turkish
elections at the very least
Polaris Al Jazeera Stockholm